[Music]
of health in Mejía with the headlines
for today, Wednesday, December 30, the
police are investigating a homicide in the
west of the valley, according to the authorities, a
son shot and killed his father in a
house near another and they look at each other, it is
reported that the  father got into a fight and
beat son and left the scene when he
returned the son shot and killed him
at this time it is unknown if
the son will be charged in other news
that unfolded last night there was a
fire in a warehouse near the hotel
scratch on the street in george roll at
about midnight where homeless people
usually camp the two-
alarm fire took two hours to contain and
one person was reported to have suffered
minor burns investigators estimate
the damage at one million dollars
on new year's eve it is  tomorrow and after the
suspension of the big end of the
year party in the script the police will now be
watching and despite the fact that there will be no
fireworks in the tourist area
in downtow  n a certain amount of people will be allowed
to walk in the freemont sweet
experience they will charge 25 dollars
to cover security charges and there
will be no live entertainment and if you are
planning to be on the strip or
downtown these items
will be prohibited bottles  or
glass containers large bags
luggage and strollers and now a look
at the weather forecast after the
strong winds we had yesterday today
we will have a lot of sun and generally
light wind tomorrow new years eve
I expect an increase in winds and clouds with
the maximum temperatures
Around 55 degrees, have a nice day,
say hello to Héctor Mejía and this was his
brief newsletter this year in Spanish
[Music]